uh okay great
okay
hi guys welcome to this youtube channel
this is exciting business
i'm here with these dummies hello mamrie
and hannah and the three of us dummies
are in a delightful dumb movie called
dirty 30.
freeze
comes out september 23rd but you can
pre-order now on itunes or you can go to
dirty30movie.com and pre-order and get
bundles with all kinds of merch
associated with the film it's real fun
check it out anybody watching who
doesn't know what dirty 30 is about it's
about a woman's 30th birthday where her
two best friends throw her a party that
goes terribly right
right i'm the old one you guys might
remember this challenge from a few years
back it's the fart
soundboard challenge it's called
variety show i'm intrigued
here we go let's see what happens
in honor of dirty 30 and it being about
birthdays which are traditional
i would start this challenge again with
hannah and mamrie to make it a tradition
for us
i love that i love it that sounds great
but we're gonna
we're switching things up last time we
just tried not to laugh this time around
we're doing three different rounds first
round
i will play a part from this
from this fart down board challenge you
can find on the internet because the
internet's great
and these two will write down what they
think the title of that fart is because
there are
amazing titles this is my job so i need
you to take it how does my mom explain
this to people
and then round two they will hear a fart
they'll have to tell me who made that
fart
well i think you should just that round
should be called who fought it
and then the third round will go back to
the old tradition and you guys will try
not to laugh
okay perfect okay so round one you guys
have to tell me the
name of this fart so you have white
boards to write them down
oh my god here we go ready oh my god i'm
so nervous
okay i'll play it again for those in the
back
okay okay i'm ready i'm ready too okay
um
hannah let's see what you think the name
of that part is i think that part is
called
cello i'm back he's got lower tones yes
and then it's like exciting up top but
then it's like hey
yeah yeah yeah hello i'm back okay
what do you think uh i named it guy
fieri's queef bucket
can i just say for the record yeah is
your favorite challenge oh my god
i just don't get it it's just you don't
know my part to make people laugh
no okay they're the silliest sounds okay
here's our next part
i got mine okay um is almost done
mamie's writing a chapter of her book
yes
hannah what is the name of part number
two i called it tiny toots
tiny toots butt art oh that's a button
it's a butt
oh that's good i named it manicotti
hottie
oh title that's a spicy heat ball
the actual name of this part is nice try
no
oh wait oh
are they trying to fart more or less
that's the real question
i'm trying to hold it in trying number
10 you work for them
extra this is the last one of this round
score is no surprise zero to zero
okay one more time
got it okay i'm ready hannah what's your
i called it bloomberg
whoa right it sounds like did you play
yeah it's a student okay memory what'd
you call it
uh she's all splat
close this one it's called push
yeah listen to it
wait i don't get a point for that i mean
no no
still zero to zero anybody's game this
round you would tell me
who fought it so this is based off your
opinion yeah this is basically what i
think
is the correct opinion of celebrity or
just pedestrian it doesn't matter
and this one i get to tell you the names
of the farts okay
all right this one is oh my god this
one's called touche
okay
[Applause]
touche oh my god wait one more time
oh my god that's a sassy fart
okay i'm ready when you guys are okay
memory what do you who fought it
a french waiter on a smoke break you see
he's getting it all out he's like he's
got a full section
he goes to have a sig and he's like i
gotta get all my farts out
because i can't be dropping the cockovan
while farting in people's faces i mean
hannah who fought it um robert durst at
the end of the game
because he's like he's like he's got it
all out
he's like nothing you can do so he's
like oh
i love it yeah i think i'm gonna have to
give it to hannah
the next fart in this round who fought
it who fought it
was called air biscuit i think air
biscuit was in the first one i think so
too
[Music]
okay memory who fought it okay remember
that hear that air biscuit again
i said it's a nun on a roller coaster
when it goes upside down
hannah who fought it okay i said someone
when they went to pee
in a crowded public restroom oh well the
glasses were
like and they like go to pee and they're
like okay i'm just gonna pee and then
they're like
oh yeah they're trying to suck it back
in i'm gonna have to give it to me
the visual okay the third part in the
round who fought it
is called anus madness no jesus
madness anus madness
like why is this you guys this kept
going for 20 minutes oh my god it's
still going
i don't even know how to get it to stop
it's like a haunted house this is the
lemonade of farts
um i would play it again but i
definitely don't want to i'm out guys
okay memory okay well you need robert
durst
i'm going for fred durst in a macaroni
grill bathroom
while getting a [ __ ] from a groupie
waitress
like he's farting the whole time
oh my god hannah who won it i did the
first caveman who ever farted and wanted
to show all the other cavemen i love
it that's so cute i wrote pro-magnum
just for clarification of what era we
were thinking
i'm gonna have to give it to mamrie i
feel like yeah
it's
you got limp biscuits you got air
biscuits now we're gonna move on into
round three the final round
where it's just a matter of uh trying
not to laugh gotta say
i'm going into this round pretty
confident i know you are i'm not so you
can't laugh at the name
okay first one is called would you like
ketchup
that's pretty funny
would you like ketchup okay and let's
hear would you like ketchup
after anus madness i feel like everybody
is so tame
i know they all seem so small okay well
just use three
okay i mean that one went to hannah very
clearly
monica you is stinky
for the last one i'm gonna play the fart
first and then i'll tell you the name
after okay got it okay give me strength
beans here we go
[Music]
okay got through it the name is feces
pieces
especially the creator of the ultimate
fart sound board whoever you are
wherever you are
thank you thank you and like another one
of the future we might need a writer and
yeah
i think our next movie should be called
monica why you so stupid
if you guys want more giggles like that
go over and check out these two dummies
channels because we shot videos over
there
all in honor of dirty 30 and don't
forget again to pre-order dirty 30 on
itunes or on 3033movie.com
woo we should make a fart called the
dirty thirty dirt oh yeah dirty 40 30.
30 30. there's so many there's so many
good things so much what would you name
your partner
let us know and buy our movie
i don't know oh
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna ask you to
play anus madness again
no i think we all know that anus madness
was truly mad
it's the new savage garden song madness